in these truly trying times many people
may be struggling with depression
anxiety and other mental health issues
unfortunately there's one very
widespread mental health issue
that isn't often discussed luckily
there's a new medication to help are you
experiencing extended periods of
happiness
feeling little to no anxiety still
looking on the bright side
something must be seriously wrong with
you
given everything that's been going on
you should be freaking out
luckily realitrex is here to help
once daily realatrex is a pro-depressant
and anxiety-inducing medication that
gives you a healthy dose of reality to
get your head out of your ass about
everything that's going on
before realatrix i used to walk all
around town with no mask on
now i realize what a pandemic and death
is everywhere
i didn't really get the black lives
matter protests
but after i took a realitrex i thought
is america
super racist turns out
it is thanks realitrex
side effects include understanding
what's really happening increased
sensitivity to what's been going on for
a long time and diarrhea
realatrex the safe scientific way to
remind yourself how awful things really
are
now available in blueberry